la joconde victime d'un acte de
vandalisme de nombreux visiteurs du
louvre ont été témoins de la scène hier
un homme portant une perruque et se
déplace en fauteuil roulant s'est
approché du tableau sur lequel il a jeté
une part de gâteau le chef d'oeuvre de
léonard de vinci est un pacte c'est la
vitrine blindée qui à tout prix
alors
sombre affaire
en tant qu'amateur d'art je vous dis ça
m'a pourri le week-end est ce que c'est
vrai que la joconde et on dit toujours
qu'on a toujours l'impression qu'à nous
regarde elle suit les regards on a fait
un essai qui c'est avoue que vous soyez
non il ya plein d'interprétation mais on
sait pas exactement
c'est courant parce que moi j'ai une
photo de jean pierre marielle voyez
quand je suis couché j'ai une photo de
georges est en jeu at en jeu 12 j'ai
l'impression que
ça c'est que jean pierre marielle
aussi j'ai pensé à la joconde
c'est arrivé trois fois depuis 1994 et
en 2007 et un tableau le pont
d'argenteuil de monnaie qui était
déchiré et du coup on a durci la loi et
maintenant dégradé un tableau qui est
dans un musée un sept ans de prison non
un cent mille euros damende possible et
même vous pouvez payer la moitié du prix
de l'offre vous imaginez
ces inestimables
spécimens
inestimable des milliards
mais bondit
les chinois dojo compte
volage on prend tout ça par mr la bar
mitzvah du petit
quoique on a aussi d'endommager la
joconde c'était en 1956 et un bolivien
il a jeté une pierre ce a endommagé un
peu le coup de gauche de la choucroute
et c'est à partir de là qu'on a mis une
vie bien pensé
c'est à partir de là qu'ils ont mis une
vitre d'accord merci ouais non la
légende dit que ce n'est même pas sûr
que cela vrais gens content qu'il soit
ou moins avoué oui mais voilà sur
brouiller les pistes pression pour
briller puisque paris la joconde
halliche est actif chez les goûts